bom primeiro bom dia eu sou o professor
velho de medicina de patologia e eu vou
tentar mostrar quais são os novos
desafios que a saúde vai ter numa
sociedade que cada vez está mais
urbanizada na medida do possível vou
fazer comparações com os sistemas
biológicos e vamos começar então bem do
comecinho onde tem registros é talvez o
no paleolítico superior já tem registro
de como viviam aquelas comunidades
era um mundo difícil você tem que correr
atrás da comida diz a comida corria
atrás de você eram ameaças importantes e
você tinha que tomar decisões rápidas e
compartilhar os medos e ansiedades
eles faziam isso nas cavernas onde eles
pintavam a vida deles e também eram os
lugares que tinham maior sonoridade e
possivelmente eles cantavam pintavam e
seguramente a fala foi precedida pelo
canto e à pintura precedeu a escrita era
um sistema muito rápido como as
bactérias são senão tinha uma estrutura
hierárquica e não passava de um núcleo e
as bactérias se mostrado muito
eficientes até hoje para se manter o
micro organismos que são que despedidos
de núcleo por força das pressões do
ambiente começa a criatividade
criatividade não é espontânea
a criatividade humana ela é fruto
se você estudar por exemplo sedimentos
geológicos na mata na américa do sul
para cássio vai ver que tem estabilidade
e cultural durante 600 e 800 mil anos
porque bastava a mesma tecnologia mesmo
a ponta de flecha cirurgia quando
acabava o alimento no lugar que tinha
pra outro se estava na beira do
naufrágio
o número não adiantava você começa então
a desenvolver domesticar animais e poder
parar com isso você começa a organizar
melhor a sociedade dividir por
especialidades
cria se então o sistema de emergência o
núcleo
e assim um protozoário e à medida que os
seres evolui você vai tendo mais
capacidades falam-se corporações ou
órgãos e você tem que se estar pegar
sistemas de mais mas com o sistema
nervoso se uma de comunicações e assim
vão sendo as cidades essa possibilidade
de especialização de origem o que a
gente chama de civilização ocidental a
gente dirigiu catedrais ou momentos
antes de saber cálculo simplesmente por
pôr as pessoas junto o relógio num bom
que acontece isso isso começa a criar
problemas de definiu bem comum
diferentemente daquilo que existia na
sociedade do paleolítico você começa a
criar segmentos mais é digamos fortes ou
equipados começam a se sobrepor já sobre
outros e esse é o caminho para você ter
as desigualdades no meio urbano e é isso
que eu gostaria de falar cidades em
geral melhores condições de saúde é em
tudo mesmo nas cidades inglesas na
quando sei quando aquela a desigualdade
fica evidente por ser separada por
poucos quilômetros é você pode saber
através de estudos de arte e patologia
que elas as pessoas mesmo os mais
miseráveis enviam pior mesmo na
revolução industrial inglesa é quando
você tem você o lobby dos ingleses
enterrarem os seus mortos nas suas
paróquias você consegue saber a data
você consegue saber a altura se
conseguem saber é quando você tem
crianças se pode saber a proporção de
crianças e de alçada de crianças e de
adultos quando você passa fome
a cartilagem de crescimento para quando
você volta comida ela volta cantando
pneu então você vê linhas nem assim como
acontece nos dentes e quando você
compara os ingleses da
do canto contada pelo de 15 por todas as
desigualdades que tinham viviam melhor
na periferia da cidade do que no campo
inglês então cidade geralmente trazem
alguns benefícios mas também por muita
gente junto também levam algumas
condições e e de favorecimento de doença
e você começa a ver que é um sistema
muito complexo roma por exemplo roma
antiga
você tem evidências de que mais ou menos
10% da população de roma tinha malária
como é que isso começa você imagina uma
cidade de 1 milhão de habitantes
quando você jogava esgoto o teu latas de
esgoto na rua se cria uma cota máxima
que o sistema de drenagem mais eficiente
mas mais bem documentado se joga na
margem do tibre o tibre eutrofizada
proliferam os kikitos ea isso você
começa a ver que as pessoas que passavam
naquele a ruim é no pântano o
impaludismo começava a ter uma febre
intermitente que depois no italiano
antigo virou ruim ou malária
quem tinha uma mutação específica na
molécula globina heterozigoto tinha
resistência então você favorece a
proliferação do plasmodium e assim foi
com a peste se imagina a sujeira rato
pulga e sim a pestes e mesmo quando não
era pedestre mas eles chamavam de teste
mas teve episódios bem documentados que
reduzir mais ou menos 30 40% da
população da europa em cada surto
as pessoas primeiro é tendiam a aliás o
depois que sobreviveu ao mistério de
viver você quer saber não quer da vida
quer saber por que você tá aqui explica
o mundo à sua volta
no início era muito fácil explicar pela
espiritualidade pode ser criar um
sistema de lógica nossas ciências
humanas e depois de kate quer explicar
por que essa como a gente vai se
entender por que a gente é
é como a gente tal porque a gente tá
aqui basicamente pelo conhecimento
como não havia conhecimento a peça era
um castigo de deus ou apenas uma regra
racionalizada para eliminar a pobreza
bom então ainda existe esse dilema
a peste as peças de hoje então a bola é
bom porque bola matava gente e você não
tinha vacina porque ela é circunscrita
pela própria mortalidade no meio da
áfrica faz aqui uma epidemia
morria 60 a 70 por cento da população
30% ano eram resistentes então se
demorava duas a três gerações para ter
um novo surto de bola e só começa a ter
a atenção quando o vetor passa a ser
também um avião ou a plantação de fruta
que os chineses vão colocando o morcego
foi na áfrica chegou na feira na beira
das grandes cidades de um morcego que
era reservatório começou a chegar na
beira das cidades aí você começa a
desenvolver um pouco de r é digamos
atenção a essa doença do ponto de vista
internacional e aí tá bem guiné aí você
tem a e veja como é difícil mexer na
cidade é mesmo a febre amarela talvez
foi a primeira doença que no brasil foi
reconhecida como transmitida por um
vetor lembrar que antigamente só pensava
até final do século 19 se acreditava
fase que você transmite as coisas
pessoalmente ou por água
o quando vêem o osvaldo cruz querendo
matar o mosquito e rápido e faz a
revolta da vacina num processo de
reurbanização uma das coisas que têm que
fazer era baixar o casario que foi feito
na rabeira com a cidade crescendo de
forma desordenada e onde moravam muitos
ex-combatentes de canudos que tinha ido
lutar contra antônio conselheiro
voltaram e não tinha ela tinha sido
prometido que ele teria um soldo
permanente e residência no brasil
shannon sempre é a previdência né mesma
situação da previdência atual né
com esse pessoal não tinha para onde ir
né
é uma parte que te fez a revolta da
vacina né
nuno e mas eles foram morar nos morros
só que no interior da bahia
eles viram um tipo de construção muito
baixa coberta com folhas que eram feitas
com uma árvore chamada favela e se cria
um novo problema na cidade mostrando que
o ecossistema muito complexo porque você
não consegue ter uma integração como eu
disse como existia nos tempos quando as
sociedades eram mais simples o que piora
quando você vem para a cidade vem te
hora obesidade doença mental e câncer
todos os recentes ajustados o resto
melhor todo indicador de mortalidade
infantil
a expectativa de vida sobe mais
obesidade
ela é bomba a chance de você ansioso
deprimido ou esquizofrênico aumenta é
uma cidade de 100 mil habitantes vai ter
metade do risco de esquizofrenia de uma
cidade de um milhão de habitantes idosos
independentes e também você tem é é o
problema do câncer no canto é fácil
o câncer é a poluição do ar e se dá
porque a gente qual é porque a cidade
com absorvem alimentos hiper processados
você respira substâncias carcinogênicas
da poluição do ar nas indústrias e você
é e algumas dessas substâncias são é
presentes no ar são disruptores
endócrinos então você tem uma
suplementação estrogênica então todos os
tumores hormônio independentes como o
tumor de mama né podem ser acelerados
por isso é bom para as duas coisas que a
obesidade e doença mental
a obesidade é um fator genético uma
dúvida tem o fator genético
você vê é quando os obesos de hoje são
aqueles que sobreviviam os períodos de
carência no passado era vantajoso você
absorveu que nem uma esponja quando você
não tinha comida e quem morria eram os
que hoje são odiados também aquele
indivíduo que com tristeza fala 'não eu
como de tudo mas não consigo engordar
isso é com o provoca o ódio que exerce
não pode dizer mas sim que eles ainda
mais se a pessoa fizer cara de
sofrimento comendo um banana split
dizendo que quer engordar e não consegue
enquanto os outros que estão chegando
tubérculos né vários estão tão assim mas
fica cada vez mais a soja crua que ele
estava comendo pra poder emagrecer tem
um componente genético lógico
hoje você tem dois tipos de gestação que
estão aumentando embora o índice de
natalidade está caindo no brasil ele tá
se estável o que tem aumentando em do
adolescentes e pessoas depois de 30 anos
a adolescente porque o mecanismo de
proteção social nas comunidades uma
menina grávida de 15 anos 16 anos só
tinha uma rede de suporte social maior
ela é obrigada a trabalhar para manter a
família e ela tem mais proteção contra a
violência e nos nós acima de 30 anos
porque hoje cada vez mais as mulheres
vão realizar a maternidade se assim o
quiserem mais tarde porque ela tem que
se estabelecer na carreira
nesses dois casos você pode ter uma
certa insuficiência relativa da face
materna da placenta eo feto correr atrás
pra em salvar o cérebro e reduza os
setores periféricos de insulina e muda
todo o processo de metabolização ou seja
pequeno para a idade gestacional morre
risco de ter obesidade e diabetes na
fase adulta têm componentes
comportamentais
as crianças hoje na rua quando estou na
rua tem uma jaula chamada parque
infantil que ele expõe a criança em uma
grade para não fugir
para não atrapalhar a violência criminal
e violência no trânsito impede que as
crianças saiam
então aquela coisa que tinha no meu
tempo a mulher que pára de jogar bola
vem comer passou para ser o contrário
para de comer e vai jogar bola
se entra no mar a cidade passou a ser um
obstáculo para as crianças e para todos
nós
tanto que tem aquela história de ter
casa moradia e escritório no mesmo
condomínio
nós temos que evoluir o conceito fazer
uma consulta à maternidade e crematório
gourmet porque o indivíduo nasce ali se
trata ali e é cremado e vira biodiesel
naquele mesmo condomínio muito bom então
as crianças não usam mais a rua outra
coisa anda com um pau de self que é o
símbolo da modernidade se tivesse que
fazer um troféu modernidade é o pão do
céu foi dividir chega assim mesmo em
qualquer lugar na capela sistina ele
está se vendo ele está ele e se enxerga
em qualquer canto
pega um potencial acadêmico e anda na
altura do que uma criança tá vendo no
mar gôndola de supermercado
principalmente no caixa
na hora que ele tá desmamando e criando
um repertório de sabores na linha pra
estimular e potável
a secção de leptina em uma ele está
acostumado a comer só de gordura e e
açúcar como recompensa ou seja ele vai
se programando para comer errado e
finalmente os mesmos disruptores
endócrinos são é são é perceber é eu
tenho que ficar aqui nessa bolinha é que
eu tenho e entende a linguagem não
verbal nem como eu sou casado há muito
tempo eu eu eu consigo entender sem
abrir a boca que eu não tava vendo agora
eu entendi o que não estava agradando
doença mental doença mental é também uma
coisa difícil né porque vamos analisar a
gente nasce a vida nasce na na paralelo
1010 ordem de declaro 10 horas de escuro
você vai migrando
pra outras atitudes e tem que deixar de
ser preto né pra poder quer fazer
vitamina d
a mudança de que qualificou a
possibilidade de se reduzir a produção
de melanina foi há 60 mil anos atrás
mais ou menos conceito de raça é
simplesmente uma considerável de
evolução e seleção natural não existe
base acaba por aí e você tem que adaptar
o seu círculo escuro qualquer um ciclo
para o escuro que a gente tem hoje
possivelmente 18 horas declaro com seis
horas de escuro onde vai se acrescentar
melatonina
quando é que se vai produzir aprofundar
o sono ruim urbano que estimulou a cópia
não deixa se aprofunda o sono
o fato decidiu acordar mais cedo pra
poder mãe para poder chegar
isso já é um bom caminho para você
colocar ansiedade dirigindo é uma
experiência de elevação espiritual em
são paulo
você se surpreende pessoas que dirigem
palavras muito duras a pessoas que nunca
viram até de familiares próximos das
pessoas simplesmente pelo fato dela ter
entrado na sua frente e o estresse que
não desliga ea pressão que toda vez a
gente tem que fazer coisas quando é que
você tem medo de abril e mail para saber
que tem que entregar um relatório alguma
coisa no dia seguinte
isso é sinal de internação compulsória
você tem que chegar colocar o indivíduo
se tem um iphone 6 depois em 4 aí você
dá um telefone sem fio quando se
contentar com uma ficha telefone que ele
tá nível para andar na sociedade quer
dizer quantos de vocês acordar de noite
anciosos sem nem saber a razão
isso é fruto da pressão da vida moderna
do estresse que não desliga
tá explicado à saúde mental qual é o
papel dos médicos então o papel dos
médicos é incorporar aos antigos
desafios da urbanidade esses novos
transporte faz parte da de prescrição
calçada faz parte de prescrição
transformar a cidade numa coisa que a
gente possa compartilhar você trabalha
até 60 70
depois se aposenta se tem mais dez anos
a expectativa de vida que você tem que
fazer e no médio ou três vezes por dia e
no supermercado conversar com caixa ou
você vai dar chance dessa pessoa andar
você tem que fazer os jovens que perdem
quatro cinco horas por dia ter tempo
para estudar e não perder 45 horas no
transporte para serem melhores cidadãos
a morar perto de um parque redução mais
ou menos 30% o risco de infarto agudo do
miocárdio reajustado para outras com
variáveis
isso é estática e beta bloqueador
combinado então caíram no colo da saúde
desafios que não são clássicos da saúde
se não resolve com vacina você não
resolvem com prescrição ou seja nós
vamos ter que fundar
nós profissionais de saúde a sociedade
protetora do ser humano desse bp de que
é de nossa responsabilidade e que vive
num ecossistema que cada vez mais cada
vez mais exige mais da gente e oferece
menos em troca muito obrigado
[Aplausos]